former President Jimmy Carter says he
believes us talks with North Korea could
lead to that country's denuclearization
we sat down for a wide-ranging interview
with the 93 year old Nobel Peace Prize
recipient his new book faith a journey
for all is out today it is published by
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS mr.
Carter left the White House nearly four
decades ago but remains a knowledgeable
source on US diplomacy with North Korea
you've been to North Korea three times
I've been there I've spent about 20
hours in detail talks with the top
leaders of North Korea I think I
understand what the North Koreans walk
and what the leaders want is our
guarantee that can be confirmed that the
United States will not attack North
Korea preemptively
as long as North Korea stays at peace
with its neighbors
president Trump has now announced he's
willing to sit down I'm glad to hear
that and hope he'll be successful I pray
that he will I've I've offered to
presidents from directly on two
occasions since he's been office said I
would be glad to help in any way even to
go to North Korea if needed I don't want
to go if I don't have to him as you said
over 93 years old but I would be glad to
do whatever he wanted me to do you mean
hold like a preliminary meeting with Kim
jong-un before Trump whatever the
president won't say it's against the law
and against my principles to intercede
without permission from the president
but if the president wanted me to help
in any way I would be glad to do that
Russia once again back in the news and
today President Trump announcing he
would expel 60 Russians from the US over
that poison attack in Britain as
president Trump taken a hard-enough
stance against Russia's meddling I don't
think president Trump has one reason I
think the main reason isn't he didn't
want to admit in any way that the
Russians were influential in his
election he wants to give that credit
directed to the American people and in
the last few weeks I think president
swap has shown
for the first time willing to stand up
against the policies of all Russia I
think he should I think he'd go a little
bit further along but I think he's begun
to change his attitude I'm almost
embarrassed to ask this question but you
know there's so many problems facing
America and people in need and yet
there's an entire discussion about this
current president and a alleged affair
he had with a adult film star what do
you make of that he'll help the
Democratic Party in 2018 and perhaps in
2020 and will be damaging to President
Trump I think most people want a
president whom they trust to tell the
truth always and who has some basic
moral values that including loyalty to
his own wife so in a way it'll be
damaging but I don't think he's going to
have nearly as much effective would have
had say 20 years ago President Carter
was in New York Monday to promote the
release of his new book a reflection on
faith and its impact on our lives what
number book is this 32 your 30 second
book well I know you're not traveling as
much know it seems like you're you're
hardly slowing down well I'm going to
slow down those are not both since roses
video she's not past 90 now and so it's
time for us to back away from some
things I know you have had melanoma and
congratulations on being in remission
now for more than two years this run
how's your health right now that's good
and what are the doctors say about your
prognosis at this point the prognosis is
good but I'm not overconfident but I'm a
lot more confident
hello's for a while and thankful I know
when you announced your diagnosis in
2015 you said you were surprisingly at
ease and in the book you write that we
thought that I had only a few weeks to
live and Rosa and I began
making plans for my death what plans
have you made well I call them all my
family together and told them that I was
going to die quite soon and I shared
that information with the leaders of the
quarter unaware rose and I spend a lot
about time so I was prepared to go but
things turned out for the better but
that's an unusual thing to prepare to
say goodbye and then I'll be granted a
great deal more time that's true well
I've been very fortunate and in many
ways yeah so do you think this is your
your last book I think so but I thought
the last one was my last one and so this
has been the most difficult book I've
ever written just about faith you know
just a simple title because there's so
many different meanings of faith right
you're talking about more than just
faith in God well faith in God faith in
yourself faith in your fellow human
beings faith in the Equality of people
in the eyes of God are you concerned
that there's a lack of faith in many of
these yeah we lost a lot of faith in
each other the eagerness to accommodate
different opinions a lot of Americans
have lost faith in themselves
we've lost faith in democracy why do you
think that faith is being challenged
it's been challenged but I still have
faith in the long term correction of our
problems I teach a Bible class every
Sunday what should I do personally as a
human being and when I asked my to 300
businesses every Sunday if they think
that our country can overcome the
challenge in education today the almost
unanimous respond yes we have confidence
in America we have faith in America and
the principles on which it was founded
so I think we still have faith in the
basic rudiments of life in this country
Oh a Jimmy Carter's such a class act
Nora he is it's a really nice book you
know not only is he studied world
religions but he studied so many
philosophers too and so the book is a
nice for you but he also brings up
issues that I think have fallen off
perhaps the front pages or the front of
our minds which there income inequality
the threat of nuclear war the idea that
you know you've done so much with
Habitat for Humanity that charity is one
way that actually brings people together
you may not agree with each other
ideologically find a lot in common
through charities so I think a lot of
values that will resonate with a lot I
love that he says he's ready to slow
down but yet he's willing to go to North
Korea I know it was a pleasure to spend
some time ago I could tell former
President Carter also spoke about the
renewed debate over guns and so to hear
why he says students from parkland
Florida could force a change after the
school shooting visit our website CBS
this morning calm